in 2006 I remember this you sang at the
Emmys with Donald Trump everyone forgets
now of course Donald Trump has become
this whole other figure but there was a
parity in the news yeah not much just
stick to your puzzles but at the time I
remembered this you did a really funny
bit were you two saying the Green Acres
theme and he was dressed up as a farmer
and you at the time thought like he's a
funny guy well okay so they had this
dumb thing on it I mean it's called Emmy
Idol which American Idol was at their
height of popularity and they asked
people to sing various TV theme songs
and so I ordinarily I'd be like no but
they said we want you to do the Green
Acres theme song with Donald Trump as
the character of Karen Walker from Will
and Grace and I was like yes yeah at the
time he was just like the kooky guy from
The Apprentice and he was like you're
fired no it was like oh he's funny so
this story centered the chores in the
fresh air Times Square I tried to say
fresh air but a black tar heroin but he
didn't want did he say he said like cut
that line he did what's black tar heroin
to somebody and they told me he was like
no no and so then so then I said Trump
Tower instead which he loves so we
thought that that was funny and we ended
up people were like voting online or
calling in their votes so we ended up
winning any Idol I know yeah
the next day I was in my dressing room
at Will & Grace and my phone rang and it
was Donald Trump and I was like listen
um we really need to win that this
doesn't sound like him at all but I
don't care we really needed to win that
and we did and you were a big part of
that so I just wanted to say thank you
we really needed to win that thing and
I'm thinking okay wait if he needs to
win any Idol that bad what must it be
like now I may be the next Queen of
England and the next first lady my
United States of America it all happened
for you and it's going to happen
simultaneously